well now you have another murder for you
mr. zepho what brings you here you know
you are there are different versions as
being work I think someone's trying to
kill me different victim same body
everybody thought it was you with your
relatives come this way you're a time
traveler I was 20 years old he appeared
on the road if it wasn't for you we'd
still be together universe is not about
you you look so much like him parallel
reality you fragmented oba seven
different versions of yourself one of
them happened to be a psychopathic
killer
what happened to Daniel just be wise to
leave well enough alone with mr. Dafoe
tampering tangulls thing - she is a
dangerous place is he a relative
everyone thought it was you the late
shift Patrol phone above the dock it
stabbed in the name it's it's me they
are dead
[Music]
what are you doing push them you accept
a wife this isn't your case Omega
retired let me ask her some questions
you can't approach your witness like
that she thinks you're her husband I'm
not will you look like you are
you